AGV: Today we're talking about
data stream, artifact registry,
and API design.
I'm AGV, and welcome to "This
Week in Cloud," where we serve
you the lowest latency news.
On top of all the data
announcements from last week,
we've also launched
Data Stream in preview.
Data Stream is a serverless
change data capture
and replication service that
allows you to synchronize data
across databases,
storage, and applications.
Creating a stream
captures data changes
from sources like
Oracle and MySQL
and stores it in
cloud storage where
you can use Dataflow to
transform the data to however
you need.
Try it out today, and stay
tuned for even more supported
data sources soon.
As a developer, you
need a secure place
to store all your stuff--
container images, of course--
but also language packages
that can enable code
reuse across multiple
applications.
Today, we're pleased
to announce support
for Node.js, Python, and Java
repositories for artifact
registry in preview.
Now you can not only secure and
distribute container images,
but also manage and secure
your other software artifacts.
If you're looking to develop,
run, and secure applications
across your hybrid and
multi-cloud environments,
look no further than Anthos.
And to learn more about
this managed platform
and how it can help you, check
out the Anthos 101 learning
series, all Anthos--
all in one spot.
APIs play a critical role
in helping software connect
and communicate as well as
making the lives of developers
a little easier.
And to make it easier
for you to use them,
we've compiled a list of
our most popular posts.
Head over to the blog for more.
If you want to read more about
any of these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the cloud.